sie soll eigentlich seine Zeitenwende
militärisch umsetzen stattdessen
blamiert sie auch ihn mit
Negativschlagzeilen doch Olaf Scholz
reagiert nicht wie zuvor nicht auf
Christine lambrechts viel kritisiertes
silvester-video
mitten in Europa tobt einbringen da
dachte ich erst dass das ist doch ein
Fake das haben doch Leute gemacht die
ihr schaden wollen also ich glaube viele
haben sich gefragt musste das sein sie
hat eine ganze Reihe von Problemen in
der Kommunikation gehabt der hat vom
Gepard als Panzer gesprochen der mit so
einem Rohr in die Luft schießt sie hat
gefragt ob sie Dienst gerade jetzt
auswendig lernen muss wer hat das sehr
sehr schwierig gemacht mit ihrem Sohn
der im Bundeswehr Hubschrauber
mitgeflogen ist und ab einem bestimmten
Punkt ist so mangelhafte Kommunikation
durchaus auch eine Frage von Eignung für
ein Amt auch in der SPD Spitze sind sie
nach dem Video tagelang sprachlos
schließlich verschenkt der Rückendeckung
für Lambrecht die Frau Ministerin
Lambrecht hat eine schwere Aufgabe
übernommen nach so langen Jahren auch
komplettes Sparens bei der Bundeswehr
und insofern bin ich sehr zuversichtlich
dass sie dort auch weiter gut
vorankommen wird und
stehe auch vollständig hinterher
Neujahrsempfang der SPD-Basis im
Saarland hier wo die SPD neuerdings
allein regiert sind sie schon weiter
diskutieren gar offen einen
Personalwechsel in der Berliner Ampel
gäbe es eine bessere jetzt könnte man
natürlich darüber streiten ob vielleicht
eine Frau stark Zimmermann geeigneter
werden viele Dinge sind unglücklich
gelaufen wenn sie weiter macht da muss
dementsprechend auch finde ich von ihrer
Seite aus bisschen mehr komme aber ob
das jetzt wirklich große Fehler sind war
die zu bezweifeln es ist unglücklich
gelaufen das muss man so sagen ja es ist
jedenfalls der letzte in einer langen
Reihe von Fehlern der Christine
Lambrecht nur noch 13% der Deutschen
sind mit der Arbeit der
Verteidigungsministerin zufrieden sie
ist nun auch offiziell die unbeliebteste
Verteidigungsminister aller Zeiten die
Opposition ruft John nach einem Kanzler
Machtwort
jeder Tag länger schafft ja nur mehr
Unsicherheit und wenn sie selber sich
schwer tut es zu erkennen mag er sein da
muss der Bundeskanzler Handeln stolz
aber macht keine Anstalten seine
schwächste Ministerin auszutauschen sie
kennen sich lange er schätzt ihre
Loyalität heißt es und sowieso dass er
sich ungern von anderen treiben
prinzipiell hat Olaf Scholz hier an
seiner Karriere so gut wie noch keinen
Minister aus seiner Regierung und dann
lassen auch keine Ministerin das hat mit
verschiedenen Dingen zu tun die
wichtigsten sind glaube ich die dass er
damit ihr zu geben würde dass er bei der
Auswahl dieser Ministerin ein Fehler
gemacht hat und Olaf Scholz gibt ja
ungern Fehler zu das zweite ist dass er
auch nicht gern das macht was ihm andere
sagen sie könnte das auslösende Moment
für eine größere Kabinettsumbildung sein
in deren Zuge sich auch Lambrecht
gesichtswarend austauschen ließe nennt
sie Faser könnte SPD Spitzenkandidatin
in Hessen werden lacht aber jede Frage
dazu bisher weg
ich bin sehr gerne Innenministerin und
setze die Themen gerade mit sehr viel
Leidenschaft um dann können Sie jetzt
sagen ich werde nicht
Ministerpräsidenten
solange nicht klar ist ob Faser geht
lässt der Bundeskanzler seinen Sprecher
ausrichten die Zusammenarbeit mit
Lambrecht sei weiter eng und
vertrauensvoll über Kabinettsumbildung
wird bei ihnen spekuliert aber nicht bei
uns dabei gibt es mindestens einen
zweiten unruhe-faktor in der SPD
Ministerriege Karl Lauterbach macht
immer wieder Fehler wiederholt z.B
sachlich falsches zum Ende der Pandemie
die Wellen die jetzt kommen die erfassen
nicht mehr die gesamte Bevölkerung
sondern nur noch die Teile der
Bevölkerung die nicht ausreichend
geimpft sind am Neujahrstag schreibt
Lauterbach rücksichtslose Gefährdung der
Rettungskräfte sollte ein Grund zur
Kündigung der Wohnung sein kurz darauf
löscht er den Tweet und aus
Ärzteverbänden kommt nach einem Jahr
unverhohlene Kritik am
Bundesgesundheitsminister
es gibt keine Zusammenarbeit mit Karl
Lauterbach er hat vom Bereich der
niedergelassenen Ärztinnen und Ärzte
selbst keine Ahnung und gibt sich nur
mit Krankenhaus Lobbyisten redet nicht
mit uns macht sich vorher auch nicht
schlau und dann brechen irgendwelche
Gesetze über uns hinein die anschließend
wieder nicht funktionieren ein Minister
im Fach so hatte Scholz ihn damals
angekündigt und eine ganz ganz
bedeutende Verteidigungsministerin hatte
der Kanzler auch versprochen ein gutes
Jahr später sind ausgerechnet diese
beiden öffentlich angezählt und Olaf
Scholz schaut zu